hey there welcome to Conan O'Brien needs
a friend I just hit Sona with a pen yeah
on the hand um it was my way of trying
to control you it was childish and I
admit that it was wrong when I did okay
do you apologize no I do not oh okay you
just admit you did something wrong but
you don't want to apologize exactly uh
welcome uh this uh this is Sona messian
who's speaking
now regular on the show my assistant and
we have a little treat today uh Matt
gorley I don't want to say it like it's
an exciting news Matt G Matt gorley
couldn't be with us today but uh sitting
in his stead uh is my backup
assistant uh who took who took over he's
kind of your main assistant now not kind
of he is my assistant because you do
nothing D David hopping David hopping
welcome to the show thank you David
hopping just in case you're not familiar
with him David hopping came in to sort
of take over Sona when you uh were with
child Yes actually with two children
yeah Mikey and Charlie you called rub
and tug I called them in the womb I
called them rub and tug but then they
were born and you christened them Mikey
and Charlie great Armenian names uh Real
Testament to your love of your Homeland
and then
um and then I really was thinking it was
going to be like Grau and and and goror
you know wow no but I mean that like
those are legitimate names right I
thought they'd be cool no the ones you
just said yeah
noan
gibberish greo and gole I don't know
I was doing my best to honor your
culture and then I realized I didn't do
any research which is a terrible way to
honor someone's culture no you doubling
down I am doubling down even better so
uh we're joined by uh someone who's
really taken up the slack and then some
David hopping you've done a wonderful
job oh thank you I mean I just want to
say everything I learned about being an
assistant I learned from oh oh and he's
doing a great job hey what's positive
reinforcement like great oh okay do you
think uh I give you positive
reinforcement yeah yeah I treat you I
treat you so much better than son you
send me like text saying like I'm doing
a good job what those aren't
me that's who is it AI that's an AI bot
that's uh we had that constructed Aaron
bler made that for me when you get those
every now and then and it just says
you're doing a good job and I value you
and things like that I have nothing to
do with that oh yeah have you noticed
that they're signed Cronin c i o n a n I
just figured you were losing it yeah
even the ones that say I'm so sorry for
your loss those are randomly General
ated cuz you haven't had a loss recently
and doesn't it confuse you when you just
wake up in the morning it says David I'm
so sorry for your loss Cronin yeah that
is a little weird but I just checked to
make sure no one I know
died oh my God David uh you tell us a
little about you're from uh I've I ask
you a lot about your your childhood your
youth you uh you grew up in a very rural
area of Southern Illinois called
Carlinville yes and I actually went
online and you know you can do street
views it is very flat in Carlinville
very flat and a lot of corn and I looked
at your house and there's just literally
like a house yes you told me your
address I asked you I went I looked the
street view it was your house and then
just corn uhuh and and way in the
distance a silo and um and then I took a
stab and said I bet you guys spent a lot
of time hanging out at the local DQ and
you said yes the DQ was huge and that's
not a put down cuz I love a Queen Dair
Queen
awes yeah but um you did right that's
pretty much your childhood was watching
the corn grow from your back window and
then hitting the DQ I mean I wouldn't
just like sit and watch it grow but yeah
I would like do other things did you
make little markings on the window like
that's the top of the Corn now no but
then come back an hour later and it's a
little higher mm I would never do that
okay can I ask you a question when you
found out where he's from did you Google
and look at where he's from just so you
could come up with things to make fun of
him for yes I did okay I thought so I
thought so okay yes I did you were doing
your research yeah yeah just as I did
with you yeah I know I know that's why
I'm I immediately got a globe of the
world and I found Armenia not a real
globe yeah and the last guy who I walked
past a computer and went to a 1940s
globe and looked up Armenia and when I
say looked up I mean spun it around
until I found it oh wow yeah
uh but anyway um you're doing a very
nice job and I bet you uh your your
family your folks back home must be
proud of you I think so yeah yeah what
do you mean I think so you're working
they do they say what's Conan like uh
people ask a lot about what you're like
yeahuh and what do you say I usually say
that you're like
nice a glowing report yeah from David
hopping um yeah you're welcome in
Carlinville anytime I'd like to go there
with you actually you play remember you
you I did some sketches with you back in
the day when you first came on and you
weren't even really my assistant yet I
forget what you were doing at the show I
think just hanging around PA well I was
your PA R your errands okay and uh I
can't remember some of the bits you did
you want to refresh if if they want to
check out David hopping you can see
these on YouTube I did that one where
they gave me a wig and I was your uh
successor yes I want I wanted to groom a
successor in case something happens to
me or I'm injured grievously injured we
want someone who could step right into
the breach and so we put a Conan wig on
you and I tried to train you to be me
yeah you chose the most awkward
person but it's funny though it was
really funny but you were really funny
it's very good if you want to you know
see what uh and I know you have your own
podcast I do called back to the best
back to the best where you explore n the
'90s '90s and 2000s yeah yeah and and
one of your big obsessions is just in
general well yeah a specific actress who
I'm thinking of oh of course Hillary
Duff yeah yeah yeah Lizzy Maguire no
she's not here this is an Oprah where
look look under your seat it's Hillary
Duff but you know you could probably get
her here right uh she won't pick up the
phone for me I can't I no I will one day
it's my quest to get you to meet Hillary
Duff oh man I don't know her I don't
really know Hillary Duff what about Sher
he really loves Sher too what can you
meet can we meet Shar no Sher is I mean
come on that's Sher what she's like a
goddess she's there's no way she's it's
just you're saying to David hey you're
doing a great job hey I'll introduce you
to your idol and then I'm over here and
it's like where's share I'll do an
impression for you okay uh Hillary
Duff's at home um and someone calls from
the Next Room Hillary con O'Brien would
like to speak to you my guess is she
says huh okay I'll talk to him right
reasonable now let's go to the share
World share what is it
share it's it's me your assistant Conan
O'Brien would like to who the
[Applause]
cares I thought he was
dead that's the impression and I think
those are fairly
accurate so you're not meeting Sher come
on but you are but you are definitely
going to meet Hillary Duff I'm going to
wear yeah so I'll take care of that the
best day I'm having the best time oh
good I love it here I got compliments
and Hillary D coming in this is great
for you thanks for having baby yeah yeah
does he call your dad jepetto no okay
okay cool you know it is nice to see
David so happy I haven't seen him this
excited since they fixed the blizzard
machine at the
DQ